what is going on everybody and welcome
to an intermediate Python programming
tutorial series or maybe better called
Python fundamentals that aren't basics
anymore okay so in this tutorial series
we're just going to be talking about
stuff that I just don't feel like fits
anymore in the Python 3 basics tutorial
series in the past I've just kind of
added on to that over time but we're
getting to the point where I just don't
think its basics so first of all like my
definition of basics is at least how I
felt when I was doing basics and that
would be like let's just make this work
right that was my goal whenever I was
first starting out so I just didn't care
that much about efficiency and scaling
and stuff like that I was just trying to
learn about the language and make it
work now with intermediate Python
programming I kind of break these down
there's kind of like three hallmarks or
trademarks of intermediate Python
programming and that is one it's
efficient and it scales well because as
you grow a project and if the project is
successful it needs to be able to scale
otherwise you're gonna have to go back
and pay off a bunch of what's called
technical debt basically so you want to
be able to scale really well also along
those lines the second thing is just
maintainability so a lot of this is just
readability and how easily we can
understand it but also just how well you
write your functions and classes and
methods and stuff like this
that allows you to actually grow over
time and improve it because a lot of
times you're just going to get to the
point where as the project grows and you
want to add new things or change things
it can become just a huge spiderweb mess
nastiness then finally the third thing
is just modularity and so the idea here
is that when you we make something your
goal should be that maybe you want to
use this in other projects of your own
or maybe other people can make use of
the code that you're writing so you want
to make something that's extremely
general generalizable that should be the
goal and that's actually really hard to
do and if you're not always thinking
about that it's really easy to take the
short route and sacrifice modularity
but also sacrifice maintainability and
even efficiency but for the most part
scaling and efficiency is more of like a
knowledge thing you just need to know
how to do it as opposed to
maintainability and modularity that's
more of like a mindset that you really
need to have so one thing I always like
to show I've shown this picture a few
times before but I think it's a really
good one is this kind of comic and the
idea is that you know you start with a
clean slate and then you build your
first project and that's just this
simple house and then over time as the
project grows you want to add these
other little things to it and as time
goes on it just gets way out of hand
everything's just kind of pieced
together there was no thought about I
mean obviously I guess this is kind of
modular but it's really difficult for
this Pradas kind of project to scale
when you're just kind of gluing things
together and again it's more like a
mindset when you're writing things
especially we're going to be talking
basically the series will start with
just some standard library and standard
functionality of Python that again just
isn't basic and then we're going to get
into object-oriented programming and so
as you build let's say your classes and
stuff like that it's like a bit more
like a mindset when you have to think
about okay how could I use this in the
future and how can I grow this in the
future and so a good test of that is
just to basically have it in a separate
file so I'm usually not somebody who's a
big fan of making these huge packages
but at least the first time you're
building in a class that can actually
help out but we'll talk more on that as
we go also in terms of maintainability I
will just point to pep 8 pep 8 is a
style guide and that's not style Bible
for Python code it's not it's not
dogmatic it's just it's more of like a
suggestion more than anything else if
you don't feel very strongly about
something
use whatever pep 8 says or if a lot of
times you might work in teams like for
example Google has their own style guide
so if you go to work for Google your
there's some differences between
Google's version of styling and pep 8
but from
a large part people generally follow the
same practices and will try to adhere a
decent amount to Pepe but there are
certain things I just fundamentally
disagree with with Pepe Don just for one
quick example will be line length 79
characters just feels unbelievably
arbitrary and it encourages you to have
like really short or like a short
function names and short variable names
that aren't descriptive aren't readable
and also to neglect sometimes having
like if especially like when you've got
a function and you're actually going to
use that function sometimes it's not
clear what that parameter is just by the
variables name so you kind of want to
have the parameters name equals variable
name but if you're trying to not not
exceed 79 characters it's really easy oh
we'll just chop off the parameter in
equals and boom we're good that's that's
Pepe that's right right I don't I
disagree with that and there's a few
other things in Pepe died just I just
feel like come on guys but but anyway um
well we'll do a lot of thing like naming
conventions we're going to follow and
stuff like that so Pepe read through it
it's it's a good read regardless it's
something to think about next we're
going to bring up a Python shell let
make it large and probably in my opinion
more important than Pepe is the Zen of
Python you should just always kind of
have this in your mind so you can just
do import this this is kind of this the
Zen of Python and basically just kind of
always be thinking of these things so
you know I'm not going to read this all
to you but beautiful is better than ugly
is one that pretty much everybody
violates simple is better than complex
is one that has unbelievably complicated
ramifications so maybe we'll show some
examples of that flat is better than
nested is also usually very complex and
or complicated so a lot of these things
are contradictory in practice practice
but it is something to always kind of
think about and try to make your code
adhere I would say adhere more to the
Zen of Python at least a line and
identify
on them Pepe but anyways keep that in
mind it's kind of a nice thing to have
so as this tutorial series progresses
you can make suggestions or
recommendations or if I do something
that you have a better method of doing
it or you think you have something
that's more it's going to scale better
it's more easily readable and it can
scale better because we're going to talk
about how scale and readability often
come into conflict with each other but
if you've got a better idea or whatever
feel free to contribute to the series so
like I said before the next few videos
are just going to be more of kind of
built in things like generators and list
comprehension that kind of stuff then
we're going to talk a little bit about
standard libraries we're going to be
talking about multi processing and a few
others like art parts and stuff and then
we'll hop into object-oriented
programming because object drawing
programming is one of the best ways to
make modular code you don't have to use
object-oriented programming but it is
one of the best ways and it's certainly
better than scripting which is most of
what we do on the channel so anyways if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise stay tuned the next tutorial
thanks for watching